here we are
in Ingolstadt and there's their stadium
this is where we're going to meet
midfielder Alfredo Morales this week's
kickoff is all about Heim at home is
where the football heart is Morales has
got a lot of high mat let's find out
more
Alfredo Morales
welcome to kick off your a Berliner your
mum's Bavarian your dad's from Peru you
play from America what is for you hi
Matt is it where you are right now of FC
Ingolstadt different places of course
where my heart is Berlin because I was
born there was I spent there my whole
life and my family's there my friends
are there and yeah obviously it's a very
special place for me and but now when I
left Berlin I came here was like yeah
culture shock and but now I feel very
very I'm very happy here the amazing
thing about English town this year is on
the road you know teams that were
expected to struggle they expect people
then although people expect them to pick
up their points at home and you guys are
mixing it up on the road how is this
possible we always have a plan with the
coaches and with the team and everybody
knows what he's supposed to do and we do
it almost every game and almost perfect
and I think if you watch a game from
English that against whoever then you
will see that everybody struggles how
did you feel back then in 2011 when
yogin Klinsmann phung's about to say hey
Alfie do you want to play for the USA
what went through your mind did you
think it was a practical joke was a
great moment I don't know it was weird a
little bit but I was very happy and I
was very proud and yeah every time I I'm
in in the US or I'm at the national team
it's it's a norm for me because it's the
biggest country in the woods them it's
the most amazing country in the world
for me your mum's Bavaria now Bavaria
soccer-mad yeah dad's from Peru there
soccer-mad so how did they react do they
go oh my god Alfie was so proud of you
or did they go why didn't you play for
Peru how about trying to for Germany I
mean how did that pan out no I don't
know my dad it supported me from the
first
moment he was very proud that I can play
for the US and he said USA is a nation
and football there is some kind of
evolution or some yeah you can see that
something happens and he said yeah this
is the right thing for you and my mom
okay for hurts
she loves football of course but for her
doesn't matter Jermaine Jones
Fabian Johnson Jurgen Klinsmann these
essentially people born and raised in
Germany who were helping to make us
soccer bigger and better it's not an
advantage for the US as a footballing
nation of course we we were born in in
Germany or somewhere else um some guys
lived in Mexico their whole life or in
South America or wherever or in Norway
we have one guy from Norway the whole
thing shows the the culture and the
history of the USA that it's just like a
met important every like different
nations and every culture can just come
together and be a country or live
together and this is some kind of the
American dream okay they're not talking
about one of your colleagues on a
national team fabian johnson you guys go
and face-to-face you're at
mönchengladbach gonna be an interesting
game you're looking forward to playing
against fabian yes of course i think
he's a great player he is uh he has a
lot of experience and he's playing and
Champions League right now and obviously
glad was doing a very very good job
unfortunately for for husband of course
but and yeah we're not scared and we
want to play a good game away and yeah
I'm looking forward to seeing and I know
him and I know how he plays and I hope
that we can just stop him maybe a little
bit so pleasure to me give I wish you
all the very best not just against glad
back but also for the u.s. national team
Alfredo Morales thanks very much buddy
thank you very much indeed guys it's no
problem we should